everybody welcome back to cronicbeats
today we're announcing the winners of
the logo competition and as always we
are joined by actually not as always
we've got the entire team together today
we've got the awesome delay designer as
well as the awesome Rudy how are you
doing Rudy hello I am great but there's
actually one more person that we need to
announce we've even got Ellison here wow
this is so funny to the four of us again
in an episode or if it's just a second
time yes yes the same time this has ever
happened but I mean the video is worth
it right it's it's worth it oh yeah
definitely this is one of the the
biggest and probably most awesome videos
for us to do at least can I say for a
minute that we've all been super
surprised by how many actual submissions
we've gotten into the contest like we
just threw it out there hoping for the
best but we were like our expectations
were blown out of the water and I'm not
even kidding we've gotten over a hundred
submissions and yeah it was actually
really tough to pick the ten best ones
and it's a quite a bit of interchanging
all kinds of opinions back and forth but
we've come on absolutely yes they've
been amazing like really well-made as
well like I mean professionally made
logos like you seen I'm impressed
yes I'm impressed yeah absolutely they
are really really good yeah and I really
can't wait to show them off oh yes I
mean at least the top ten we have yes so
the way that we'll be doing this is
we've gotten a top ten which has been
calculated by all sorts of algorithms
and interesting computations actually
this is all thanks to the lady let's I
know who might as well be called a lady
planner at this point have I ever said
that the lady is probably the one person
who is keeping the entire qawalli
project together if it weren't for all
the planning and trying to get us on the
rails when we keep going off the rails
it we couldn't have done it without you
lady especially myself I've been crazy
off the rails oh not just you it's also
me I have been as well during the series
but like for this last few weeks I
thought yeah we should try and just do
this and not delay anything since you
are leaving to Japan and so would you
start removing number 10 and just just
go with the flow
all right yeah I think that's the first
thing okay so logo number 10 has been
made by Christian wash you lose key I
sure hope that is the right one
and you guys can see it right now the
logo I send the logo right now
and yeah I think I I think I really like
this one especially with the bird yeah I
don't know I just like it the color
scheme and everything yeah yeah and we
have to add I mean it's still one of the
top ten out of hundreds no it was
actually a hundred logos or even more I
don't know but it you know a tenth place
is really good it's not that it's the
tenth place it's the tenth out of really
a lot of logos so yeah it's I think it's
beautiful because it really it really
fits the style the the beautiful wife of
quali with all the colorful assets and
you know absolutely I like it
I love it do you have anything to add I
thought the funny thing about this logo
actually I do love the way that this
logo looks like it is one of the most
happy and cute logos in there probably
actually the cutest ones but I one of
the things that I found really funny
about this one and the way that we voted
on all the logos is we all gave points
to certain logos and then lady put that
all into a scheme so not only can you
see like what place every logo has we
can also see who gave how many points to
which logo and this is the logo that
lady gave by far the most points to
which I thought was pretty funny like
you can really see this sort of personal
opinion coming through in that in that
little scheme but for me this was
personally actually one of the lower
ones since even though it was one of my
favorite looking ones like I absolutely
love this logo there's just something
about the fact that some of the assets
weren't completely made by the person
who put the logo together and that just
sort of subtracted some points for me
but still all together yeah it's a great
big yeah yeah and I might just call out
the name again because I'm sure pretty
sure he was German because he wrote the
message in German or at least partly in
German so it should be Christian
Vasilevsky if I don't get that correct I
thought it was probably yeah yeah all
right but thank you so much for
submitting all right so logo number nine
has been made by page brand and also a
very nice local totally different from
logo number ten but I really like this
one as well it's more like yes yeah yeah
that one basically is also I had to
watch over it again and again and again
it's it got better by the time looking
at it so at the first point when we had
the top 10 I was there that was maybe my
lowest one now I should say but the more
time I spent looking to it it kind of
got me even more and I think that's a
good one to talk about their logo or
maybe a graphic in general if you look
at it in its gets better
that's a good one and I like how it
works with the qawalli as the sky or
water I don't know it could be sky or
water and then the beach has actually
the sandy beach that's cool like yeah
really nice absolutely I just think is
very clean like yeah gotta keep your
mind as well like having it on a
thumbnail for YouTube right yeah
stand up because so clean in design and
like this yeah this is actually a
perfect logo for a youtube series the
thing that for me actually though stuck
out is I like this one but it doesn't
feel like it's it's qawalli Beach and
nothing else like you could have used it
for another beachside park or resort and
that's the one thing that for me sort of
subtracted some points from this one I
hate to be the negative person every
every logo submission like I still love
this thing but it's it's one that for me
I had to subtract some points too
because it's it's not inexplicably
quality beach but it's it's a great logo
even even still and I think it could
have some sort of potential if you just
use it for something else maybe in the
future and just save this idea because
it's a really cool idea yeah I mean you
can really exchange the the letters and
and it will still work and that's maybe
alter the downside of it as you said
awesome so Thank You Paige okay number
AIDS is from Erin Roberts and this one
was actually sending in five different
color schemes but yeah I really like how
that palm tree is like floating under
qawalli Beach I really like that design
and the color scheme and with the sand
and yeah I really like this one as well
yeah I mean maybe I just take over a
sylph spot now keeps him and that one
for me is is from the design part of it
I really love that one and it might have
even been one of the strongest for me
actually the colors made it a little bit
because it was sent in in the different
versions but it all was down to the you
know the borders of the graphics and
with shadows without shadows and stuff
but still it kept to the you know
pinkish reddish tone and on its own it
looks really nice but I think the vibe
and the colors of quality Beach are not
that kind of
colors and that's what made it from me
impossible to choose as the best one
from the design standpoint it might be
one of the bests even maybe the best bit
yeah yeah this thing is super clean
mm-hmm I really love the look of it but
like you said it's it's not as an
explicably come on of each I think yeah
that's true but yeah it's definitely
great one of my personal favorites I
think if I remember correctly yes eight
points I guess sorry to like that I
could remember that because we can't
check that one later
all right Carol is do you have anything
to add
and not much I like it once again for
you to found a perfect perfect logo
oh yeah mind me my tea yeah for us is a
YouTube versus oh hey Ron yes Erin
Roberts I don't know it's I don't know
but thank you for submitting your logo
alright so number seven from Jake
Southgate and this was also one of my
favorites
it was so hard any entities um but I
really like this one too like with the
color is having a volcano and stuff and
the coaster in it this is what I mean
they are so professionally made yes
totally
people are so creative I personally like
that one a lot I just don't know why I I
don't even know how many points I gave
for it but oh I can see you gave it nine
points just given that yeah the thing is
I don't the problem was I can't even
explain I love it
really much but for some reason I knew I
couldn't give it them the most points I
don't know why it was just something is
missing but I can't even explain I can't
even explain I like it from kind of
every standpoint but I just don't know
why but it's it's super great it's for
me personally one of the bests yes
it is alright so we are going to wait I
think we forgot to club for Lorenzo okay
awesome
so now we have number six and number six
has been mate by Lorenzo Massey but it's
a really nice logo as well for me this
really felt like one of my total
favorites but as you said with the other
logo it didn't really feel like a quali
beach theme even though I totally love
like that I don't know how you call that
thing in the middle but I totally love
this logo but it just wasn't for qwali
Beach it looks a little bit angry is she
really a bit dangerous or something yeah
that's the sort of vibes I was getting
from it as well and this is one of the
most professional-looking if not the
most professional looking lo we've
gotten I think yeah I think what we can
add to this as well as it would fit to
the volcano area like spot-on oh yeah
but it it's simply lacks than the rest
of the park a little bit and yeah if we
would have gone for you know logos on a
map for different areas that would be
definitely the one to choose for the
volcano area yep we could have maybe
even used all of the logos like I can
imagine a lot of different users for
different areas for something snow goes
since they you know every logo has a
slightly different feeling which is
really cool Corrales did you like this
logo I love this how much did you like
it I like it quite a bit because I mean
as cell-cell you know it's super
professional like it's very well made it
might be a little bit hard to see like
you know like read out the text itself
mm-hmm as it is mm-hmm
but still very professional yeah totally
love it thank you Lorenzo Massey for
sending this awesome logo in number five
is from Leonie a timer smile yes a
and this one was also one of my
favorites damn I seriously just couldn't
choose this one was really really nice
and yeah I don't know it's it's just
amazing like it has something from
everyone in it like you see the temple
and the turtle and equally your resort
what is it called again
Bora Bora Bora Bora huts yeah yeah it's
it's really really nice and really well
done I totally love it yes thank you
anything to add it's a very wholesome
logo I don't know what's awesome about
it it's just it fills you with joy it
just it just frames is called a beach so
nicely like the we need the purple
turtle everything is perfect yes it
definitely is for me it's also the best
art style
full-stop it's simple yet playful all
right shall we clap thank you so much
for sending in your awesome logo Lanie
okay number four is from Winston lemon
also Dutch I think Winston lemur are
also amazing yes you start guys tell me
what you think very clean very yes
frames everything in a very tight space
we get the elephants we get some some
some some palm trees that we need that
little like coaster just looking around
the Rising Sun in the background it's so
hard yeah it is entrance right the
building you see noticed for me those
silhouettes really make this thing like
the way that the white elephants strike
out against the dark background of the
entrance but then the medium like
darkness volcano behind it it's hard to
describe it but the way that all the
silhouettes work together is beautiful
yeah I mean that might be a little bit
way too much into graphic design in
general but it's really hard to make
these kind of flat and simple logos and
then give it a deaf
you know that you really have this kind
of layers yeah
the slight gradients I feel at Stewart a
lot right and and it's if you look
closely to it it's just not a light blue
it has a a little bit of a shift in it
it goes from you know slight blue into
nearly white for the elephants and then
it goes from the same slight blue into a
little bit darker blue for the volcano
and then it has the plain blue for the
middle part of it so it adds a little
bit of a you know a 3d effect you know
it's completely flat and that's true
beautiful you'll even see that slight
gradient on the text itself as well as
the so nice but yeah it's it's really
cool yeah
really one of my favorites as well I
totally love this one alright thank you
Thank You Winston liver and now we go to
the top three going so fast alright so
number three also a very nice logo oh
man
and this one is made by Matteo dura
mater D yes I mean from that his name he
should be the designer right I mean this
name is just this name is just made by
damn I know but I'm mad I just can't see
already his signature on a painting
Matteo but I'm battling no this is this
this is a piece of art in general like
this is this almost transcends being a
logo I feel like it's got such a unique
style to it like you can recognize
everything but everything is made that
has been made just a little bit more
pointy like it's a little bit more edgy
than the way that really is in implants
cause like you can see an art style in
it and that's something I really love
about this one yeah exactly
for me just I was really hard it has one
thing I would have count this as my very
favorite to be honest because the only
thing is unfortunately the the font yeah
yeah well the same it's yeah it's
beautiful but I would have wished and I
was like that it was long I know could
you have just chose another fun
and it would be for me personally BAM
that's it but yeah so the font was the
one I couldn't go for yes I love the fun
but it's just not that clear to read
yeah yeah
so but I aren't totally lolled font as
well and again that Matteo use different
types of things in this logo from things
we made and Quan Li Beach them so
awesome really awesome they're so much
in it as well I love the choice for the
restaurant as well yeah it's my
restaurant Wow but your roof no but
really nice thank you so much Matteo and
congratulation with beam number three
[Music]
now now we get to number two guys I'm so
excited I love it I love this one it is
such an amazing logo like I mean yes
ah can someone tell Callie it's a lovely
name but it's really difficult to say is
it Victor or Gaudi you're a gal I know
but it's a beautiful name I think yeah
it sounds really nice if we say it right
but okay back to the logo awesome yeah
this logo is I feel bad not giving this
the first place or not being able to
give this a first place like the first
place deserves it as well like that's
not what I'm saying but it just it feels
better to look at this thing and not
being able to say this is gonna be it
it's just yeah it's so good as well like
this is where I really felt hard where
it really felt hard to make a choice
because this thing has everything the
thing that I love most about this is how
everything's very stylized
it has everything coming back that makes
qawalli qawalli like the volcano the the
patterns on the volcano and but
everything so stylized and that's what I
love about his logo that's right there's
just one problem for me one and and we
still have to say something about this
I'm sorry but it's
nothing about the logo itself I think
it's everything perfect the only thing
is our thinking of a teepee tent in the
and that was the you know the one from
the in oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I know me and that was the only thing I
was a little bit confused and so I just
you know but I mean that's so it's very
beautiful I love this one really very
much
yeah I think I think this was my I think
I think this was it was horrible victory
my heart you the winner
right I think it was no it was no it
wasn't actually Victor no I think it
back okay your but your logo did not cat
it no actually every one of you voted
for a number one that is number one
right now except for me because that was
my second favorite and I had number four
as my favorite but that's totally fine
okay so let's oh yes your awesome logo
it's really really great to see all you
guys making so many awesome stuff for us
just for us like we're doing YouTube and
awesome just having fun and you Duke
amazing logos you guys are gonna get
somewhere in the world oh yes yeah some
of this stuff is just so good all rights
are we ready for number one
okay here it comes
yes stylized letters a rainbow
simplifying some shadows like we have
shadows in the park it's beautiful why
if it only wasn't a comic sense all
right okay no but we need to explain
this right like in I think it was
somewhere in the first few days and that
we got the email of our lovely community
manager Bo and she was like okay I'm not
like seriously sending in a logo but I
just want to tell you I love your
project and I love you guys and so I
just thought this will be funny to
mention before yeah all right guys let's
go to a real number one all right no
here it goes guys
I'm totally in love with this one here
it wasn't my favorite but now it is like
when I see it how we already used it
which we can't tell yet but yeah I'm
totally in love with this one yeah well
from for me seeing this the first time
and he did also like he sent us a
preview of this logo how it looks and
immediately I was I was sure that this
might be my winner if there isn't
anything else which could blew me away
like that did mm-hmm
yeah and it is it holds true until the
very end and with all the other awesome
logos which I have to say they are
really awesome but this one I'm a fan of
clean logos but still give giving it a
little bit of touch you know and this
one combines everything I do understand
if there are people who say it might not
be colorful enough or you know lacking
some some personal elements or stuff but
really what what I think what we wanted
to capture is kind of a logo that stands
out for qwali Beach you know something
which you wouldn't see anywhere else in
a beach resort or something that so
something which is really unique
but recognizable at the same time and I
think that's what this logo really
delivers I I agree with this actually if
you look at a lot of theme park logos
they are very colorful very busy you got
all sorts of elements from the theme
parks themselves and well I think it's
awesome and while they strike the right
points for everything of logo design
like they have recognizable silhouettes
they're very simple they've got the
elements of the park there's something
about this thing that's unique and
completely different from other theme
parks that I just love about it and I
feel like you could use it in a in a
large variety of ways as well this is
just a simple basis but there's a lot to
build from this yeah and as Perez
mentioned in the beginning like for a
logo what's the crowler's I'm not really
sure like for a logo when you have it
covered on something in your videos then
the simplicity just does the trick in
this case I totally love it it's it's
it stands out it's yeah exactly it's
kind of like it's kind like you know
like like the Starbucks logo for example
I'm not saying this reminds me of it but
you know it's it's kind of like very
simple design wise but it's you can
recognize it straight away right sample
yeah so it's kind of like you can put it
on like a mug you can put it on a
t-shirt you can put it but just just
frames it so nicely I love it copy yeah
thank you so much Sam it was really
really we have to read out the name
completely I think it might be French
maybe I tried in French though it could
be Chhavi a mano
sounds nice okay you say that again
please
it must be chef Yi Mondol well I could
just hear this that's sexy I was
expecting SIL to say that but it's you
don't want to hear much no I don't you
think it's sexy
oh right oh hell yeah you see it no but
it's really really nice and we all
agreed that this one is just a best
local yes hopefully is from France
because otherwise I messed up his name
completely congratulations
we're being number one and and as
mentioned before we will use this logo
of course in some final videos don't
worry about that it's gonna be awesome
and we totally love to use your logo
just for the final episodes and all we
might have to mention you have a lucky
one getting the great prices so we are
getting in touch with you we are you the
email you sent the logo I guess yes and
sort it all out for you and yeah
congratulations man exactly and so that
was like the planet coaster signed copy
you got the deal seized and you get a
goodie bag with a mousepad what was it
again damn I totally forgot and of
course the expo
so I really hope that you are able to
come to the Expo and yeah we you can at
least meet me and Rudy and hopefully
Sylvain karelis you weren't able to come
right I'm not going to the Expo I'm sad
but well let's let's just keep our
fingers crossed that Silve will be there
and then we hopefully can meet you in
person on the expo double so awesome so
let's hope for him that he's from the
north of french yeah just fly over then
we're just used a train tunnel or a car
I don't know he's from France because
there was some other French speaking
countries in this world as well oh yeah
that's right alright so thank you guys
again a silver its edge for submitting
this awesome logos it was really such a
tough choice going through more than a
hundred logos it was terrible but so
much fun like but it was terrible in a
good way like it was just so many
positive vibes and so many positive
comments and yeah even among the 90 plus
logos that didn't make it say for a few
logos that was just some random economic
sense and stuff like all of the logo is
really good and it was hard to even get
down to the top ten so congratulations
everybody in a way it's been awesome
yeah and it's been great to have such an
amazing response to our very quick
actually idea of getting this
competition out there well I would just
like to thank everybody for entering in
the competition and yeah that's just
about it I guess actually I'm not yeah
this video will be coming out hopefully
still on the 23rd which is as we speak
right now so we'll see how quickly we
can get this out but stay tuned for the
upcoming days since we have lots of
videos planned using this logo as well
in the very near future and we've got
all sorts of cinematic videos of the
park of the coasters as well as some
secret
other stuff that you'll be seeing
popping up in the next few days so yeah
stay tuned for some great stuff and
thank you guys for watching this video
the thanks for from all the qawalli
people and see you guys in the upcoming
videos bye guys bye the earth